this is a super interesting peek behind
the curtain there are now multiple
reports out
that privately donald trump jr believes
that donald trump is going to lose in
november
and lose badly and fascinatingly don jr
reportedly believes
that not only donald trump but don jr
and maybe other members of the family
are going to be indicted and prosecuted
if donald trump loses
uh loses in november this is so
interesting
in terms of what it says about their
realization
about what's going on despite always
claiming everything is great so the new
york times has an interesting piece
about this where
they quote a prominent conservative
activist who was interviewed on the
condition of anonymity
who told the new york times that don jr
thinks they're going to lose in november
and that when they lose they're going to
get quote really hurt
meaning that federal prosecutions of not
just donald trump
but of his family and political allies
may be an inevitability
and according to the same conservative
activists don jr believes that a biden
administration will not
peacefully transition but they will
instead
shoot the prisoners was the term that
don jr used although that
particular piece was later denied by
andy serabian who's another republican
operative
so there's a few different things here
first let's deal with the prosecution
you could say if you're innocent you
don't
fear being prosecuted that's fair but
it's really easy to counter in this
particular case because
if you believe that there will be
politically motivated
partisan political attacks you could
take the position that the next
administration will prosecute you
not because you committed crimes but as
political payback now
there's of course no evidence of that if
joe biden wins
and there are prosecutions of the trump
family it would be because there's
evidence that they committed crimes not
because of some personal vendetta by joe
biden
but for me the more important revelation
is about donald trump's desperation to
win
if don jr really believes
that there's a risk of prosecution if
joe biden wins in november
that must be at least somewhat in donald
trump's mind
at least a little bit and it would
explain donald trump's
willingness to do anything to win in
november and we've talked about this
before
donald trump may genuinely believe that
he must win in november to avoid
prosecution
i actually don't think it's likely i
think the trump organization
will be gone after for financial crimes
and it won't touch
trump personally but if trump thinks
it's a possibility
he is like a cornered animal that's the
analogy we've been using and cornered
animals behave erratically that tells us
why
trump will use the post office and try
to suppress vote by
mail and try to close polling places and
contest the election results and call it
rigged and welcome foreign interference
because trump may see this
not just as fighting for his political
life and his reputation as he may see it
but as the way to keep himself out of
prison or at least out of a courtroom
for the rest of his life now just
imagine for the sake of following this
imagine if biden wins and makes hillary
clinton attorney general
and imagine that she oversees
prosecution of the trump family
when it was trump in 2016 running on
lock her up
i don't deny that there would be
something interesting about that but
let's put it aside here and and not
really put the cart before the horse
the real takeaway is that a quarter
cornered animal will lash out in ways
that are incredibly dangerous and
violent
and that's what we have to expect over
the next 10 weeks here it is 10 weeks to
the day
today until november 3rd now my real
concern
is that trump won't lose in november and
that
i can't exactly put my finger on it but
over the last two weeks
i've started to lean closer to thinking
a trump re-election is more likely than
it was a couple weeks ago
polling might be a part of it polling is
certainly tightened a little bit in late
june biden was averaging
plus 10 nationally now biden is
averaging
plus 7.5 so that's part of it
but there's something intangible that i
can't quite put my finger on
that has me more worried today about a
trump reelection
than i was two to three weeks ago let me
know what you think it might be
we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram page
at david pakman show while you're there
follow me on instagram
at david.pakman if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video